et en bourgogne emmanuel macron peut
compter sur le soutien de françois
patriat le sénateur socialiste de la
côte-d'or en duplex avec nous depuis
paris françois patriat vous êtes donc en
marche pour une nouvelle campagne elle
s'annonce difficile
toutes les campagnes sont difficiles
mais celle-là est exaltante
c'est exaltante parce que c'est un
candidat hors norme
quelqu'un un candidat qui a aujourd'hui
une vision qui a un projet pour la
france qui veut à tout prix refonder la
démocratie notre système politique et
donner un message à tous les français à
tout le peuple de france à celui qui
réussit il ya celui qui souffre je pense
que il a aujourd'hui la dimension la
volonté le charisme pour pouvoir le
faire c'est la raison pour laquelle
certes je soutient emmanuel macron nous
sommes déjà plus de 2000 en bourgogne
près de 3000 à le soutenir dans sa
démarche
alors françois patriat être candidat
c'est une première étape mais il faut
500 parrainages d'élus pour se présenter
ce sera votre mission en bourgogne de
rallier les élus se donnent a déjà
commencé et il ya des ya déjà de grands
élus aidés des grands élus des maires de
grandes agglomérations qui nous ont
rejoints et puis il ya aussi des maires
du territoire rural qui spontanément
m'ont écrit m'ont téléphoné pour me dire
'est-ce que vous souhaitez est-ce que
vous souhaitez avoir mon parrainage vous
le donne bénévolement je considère qu'
il n'y aura pas de problème pour avoir
les parrainages pour emmanuel macron
avec déjà tous les adhérents en mars par
les mecs et parmi lesquels il ya des
élus et rauque un problème pour avoir
les 506 pts heures vous êtes un fidèle
de la première heure il est venu vous
rendre visite à dijon lors de votre
convalescence après votre accident de la
route
vous avez tous même l'étiquette ps ça
peut être facile forcément pour
démarcher ses élus vous êtes socialiste
mais vous roulez pour un non-socialiste
pas je roule pour quelqu'un qui dit je
ne suis pas mon bout du parti socialiste
mais je suis de gauche
et puis je vous rappelle que le message
solennel de ce matin ce régime dans
cette phrase je ne suis pas là pour
rassembler la gauche pour rassembler la
droite qui suis là pour rassembler la
france
je crois qu'à un moment où on a des gens
qui sont une forme d'archaïsme si bien à
droite qu'à gauche
souhaitent pas travailler ensemble
souhaitent rester dans l'antre soit des
cénacles et des partis pendant un
maillage les français redoutent oui
françois hollande est et archaïque selon
vous je parle des partis politiques
je parle des partis politiques du
fonctionnement des partis et dont je
pense que dans le parti socialiste il ya
des gens ce qu on appelle les frondeurs
qui aujourd'hui pour moi sont les
archaïques
oui bien entendu je le pense dans les
pas du chef de l'état pour lequel j'ai
du respect et que je n'ai jamais
critiqué
emmanuel macron veut chambouler le
système politique il vient de la finance
il n'a jamais été élu
serait-il comme un donald trump plus à
gauche
je crois qu'ils sont pas comparables il
y à il y a une forme de noblesse de la
démarche des manuels bacon qui n'est pas
dans la démarche donald trump
il ya une vision et une vision pour ce
pays et les ce qui différencie emmanuel
macron des autres candidats potentiels
que je connais aujourd'hui ceux qui
veulent être demain c'est que tous les
autres candidats ont une vision du monde
tel qu'il a été avec des recettes telles
qu'elles ont été alors qu emmanuel
macron ils voient le monde tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui dans sa globalisation dans
sa mondialisation avec ses avantages
mais aussi avec ses draps mais avec les
difficultés qu'ils engendrent et les
réponses qu'il apporte son pour ce monde
de demain on apportera demain avec les
voilà donc c'est ce qui différencie des
autres
en quelques mots françois patriat quel
rôle précis vous allez tenir dans cette
campagne savoir que les choses soient
bien claires je ne suis pas là pour
convoiter une place un poste ou un poste
futur je suis là aujourd'hui pour
accompagner manuel dans sa démarche de
rénovation de la vie politique donc
c'est pour rénover la vie politique
c'est pas pour m'y inscris toi même
mais c'est pour que cette démarche
réussissent pour les générations
suivantes pour le pour le renouvellement
générationnel pour le renouvellement des
hommes politiques pour qu'il n'y ait
plus cette cassure entre ce qu'on
appelle à tort les élites et le peuple à
côté et donc je vais faire la campagne
la place sulu où il voudra bien de ce
soir d'aller à la rencontre des élus des
territoires avec le mouvement d'aller
faire des réunions d'aller sur le
terrain rencontrer tous les acteurs de
la ruralité de la ville
des banlieues les entreprises que je
connais bien de l'agriculture de la
nature par ailleurs j'essaierai
d'apporter avec d'autres avec d'autres
maintenant puisque nous sommes très
nombreux et que nous serons cent mille
dans les jours qui viennent
vu le monde droit d'adhésion que nous
que nous avons encore enregistré depuis
ce matin à pouvoir faire cette campagne
dont une campagne il m a semblé
j'entends bourgogne merci françois
patriat je rappelle qu'un métier en
duplex et 2 paris pour évoquer le début
de cette campagne d' emmanuel macron
merci à vous 6